[birds chirping]
[indistinct television]
- UM, HI.
ARE YOU EARL PEELE?
- WHO THE HELL WANT TO KNOW?
- [exhales sharply]
I THINK I'M YOUR SON,
JORDAN PEELE.
- OH, OKAY, I SEE.
COME ON IN HERE FOR A MINUTE.
CLOSE THE DOOR ON THE WAY IN.
- ALL RIGHT.
- ALL RIGHT, MAN, GO AHEAD
AND HAVE A SEAT THERE.
I'M GONNA EXPLAIN SOMETHING
TO YOU.
- OKAY.
[both sigh,, sniff, grunt]
- I AIN'T YOUR DAD.
ALL RIGHT,
I'M SORRY TO DISAPPOINT YOU,
BUT THAT'S
THE SITUATION, BROTHER.
- ARE YOU--
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING?
- HUH?
- WE'RE DOING THE SAME THING.
I-I ALWAYS DO THIS.
I ALWAYS SCRATCH
THE BACK OF MY NECK
LIKE THIS
WHENEVER I'M IN
AN UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATION.
- SCRATCH MY NECK, MAN.
EVERYBODY SCRATCH THEIR NECK.
I BREATHE IN AND OUT TOO, MAN.
NOW EVERYBODY MY KID?
- OKAY, LOOK AT THIS.
THAT'S A PICTURE OF ME WHEN
I WAS A BABY.
THAT'S MY FATHER.
- THAT AIN'T ME.
MAN, LOOK, LOOK, MAN,
LOOK AT THAT DUDE'S AFRO.
LOOK, I GOT THIS
GOING ON, MAN.
MY HAIR IS GRAY,
HE GOT BLACK HAIR.
I MEAN, HE HANDSOME AS HELL,
BUT I AIN'T NOBODY'S DADDY.
- I'M SORRY.
I'VE JUST BEEN LOOKING
FOR HIM EVERYWHERE.
- YEAH, YEAH.
I'M SURE YOU HAVE.
- IT'S JUST,
I GOT MY OWN TV SHOW NOW.
[sighs]
I DON'T KNOW,
I JUST--
I KNOW THAT WHEREVER HE IS,
HE--HE WOULD BE PROUD.
- Y-YOU GOT YOUR OWN TV SHOW,
HUH?
- YEAH.
- YEAH,
I'M PRODUCING AND ACTING.
- MM, OH, YOU, OH,
YOU PRODUCING AND ACTING!
RIGHT, OKAY, YEAH, THAT--
OH, THAT--THAT'S MY BOY.
[laughs]
- [laughs]
- YEAH, LOOK AT THAT, MAN,
WE DOING THE SAME THING.
WHAT IS THAT?
HOLY [bleep].
THAT'S GENES RIGHT THERE, MAN.
'CAUSE YOU CAN'T DO THAT
UNLESS YOU SHARING MAD GENES
WITH SOMEBODY.
IT'S GOT TO BE IN YOUR DNAs.
- NO.
- [gasps] OH!
- ALL RIGHT.
- YOU MY SON.
- NO.
- MY BABY BOY!
- THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
- YOU COME BACK HOME, MAN.
I MISSED YOU SO MUCH,
LITTLE MAN!
- OKAY, HEY, STOP IT.
STOP--GET OFF, GET OFF!
JUST GET OFF--GET OFF!
- GET OFF, WHA--OH, HEY.
OH.
- [sighs]
WHEN I FIRST CAME TO YOUR DOOR,
YOU WOULDN'T EVEN ACKNOW--
OKAY.
- OKAY.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN I FIRST CAME IN HERE--
- I FIRST CAME IN HERE--
- STOP THAT!
- WHEN I FIRST CAME IN HERE,
YOU WOULDN'T EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT I COULD POSSIBLY
BE YOUR SON.
BUT NOW,
ONLY AFTER I TELL YOU
THAT I HAVE MY OWN SHOW
ON COMEDY CENTRAL--
- WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
COMEDY CENTRAL?
GET THE [bleep]
OUT OF MY HOUSE!